when you are free diving in the Years
prior there is no risk you don't have
any other gas in your lung that what you
are breathing the only Rises come short
of air and then you're in trouble which
happened to me uh one time seriously so
tell me about that time I got to ask you
about free diving before we return to
the rebreathers well all these legs I
had altitude they are cold they are the
minimum temperature that you can have on
bodies of water uh clear bodies of water
which is for degree C it's very very
cold and so you keep such a nice path
yeah
so you cannot
um
just dive with a wetsuit
so the idea was to take a dry suit and I
learned how to free dive with a dry suit
which is really the worst thing you can
do what's a wetsuit what's address so a
dry suit a wetsuit is usually what you
use in the ocean when it's not too cold
you can use also dry suit but the
wetsuit basically is going to keep you
warm because water is getting into the
suit and at the contact of your skin is
getting to body temperature and so for a
while you can you know dive like that
and need in the ocean here that's fine
that that that's fine the dry suit is
the opposite it's completely closed
which means that you don't have any
contact with the water outside and you
keep your warmth through your body
temperature and even clothing that you
can put into it so this dry suit they
are used by either go really deep in
very cold water and need to stay a long
time underwater so what's the bad part
the bad part is that
when you have those uh dry suit
you have a lot of air that can be
trapped in it usually we do what we call
burping the suit it's not very pleasant
expression but you get in the water and
as soon as you get in the water you can
see the air pockets all over the place
right so you burp the suit you open the
valve and the air comes out once you
have done that then you look with your
lead belt and and you know when you're
ready to go down and so what happened
that day is that I actually did verb the
suit but didn't realize I burped it
completely and so I went down
and immediately I felt an air pocket
going to my legs so basically air was
trapped in the suit and went
on my legs as I was diving like that and
so I didn't pay too much attention to
that because you're diving down yeah I
was driving down and so didn't pay too
much attention about that as I was you
know busy at just an awkward position
but
then I wanted to turn and go up
well no can do I was just like a buoy
and I was like that so uh the first time
I say okay I tried a second time and the
third time and by the fourth time I kind
of realized I was in trouble and the
fifth time I say okay now you better
give it your best try otherwise it's
gonna be big trouble
um and you're this is free diving I was
free diving and then you can and I
cannot hold you feeling I mean is there
a panic or no there is no panic because
you can't you cannot afford to be
panicking in fact you are always
thinking because there is training this
is the best part about training your
training allows you that space to keep
you cool
and and compose which you need to be in
that kind of situation and so finally
after the fifth time I was able to
rectify the position and get myself up
but when I got up my lungs were empty I
had been in the water for quite some
time and I of I knew what was going to
happen so I decided to just be the plank
you know not move and don't do anything
just open my mouth and try to suck
oxygen but obviously oxygen at six
thousand meters 20 000 feet there is not
that much it's about a little it's a 48
of what you breathe at sea level
so although it was noon at that time
the skies that pretty dark and starry
foreign
can you possibly train for that like
because can you also pass out oh you
could I mean the fact that I was already
seeing dark was a real sign that my
brain was starved of oxygen and I had
one of my uh friends or colleagues on
the on the shore just telling me because
I'd been under for a little while and
say is everything okay and I I remember
trying to say something and and I was
just like
oh that's I think the best lie I ever
ever I get the thumbs up you're lying to
the friend and maybe to yourself uh no
uh because I knew I was going to be okay
but it took me to be still just for a
few minutes
well can you talk about free diving I
mean what's the technical skill involved
here it just seems um
it seems exceptionally difficult like
for most people that swim you go
underwater it's it's hard so what what's
the skill there you know I think
you probably can get good or better at
freediving by training so you have
different techniques uh you can train in
swimming pool and you can say you know
frankly for me
um I go at the bottom of the swimming
pool and I sit there and then you have
relaxation uh techniques some people
meditate I can't I am not a good person
that can meditate or if I do I don't
know about it and but
um my way of doing things and and taking
my mind off the situation I'm in is by
singing my head I I love music or
hearing music and in fact knowing the
kind of song I'm singing I know about
the length of time that I'm staying on
the water as well so this is how you
know so this is my own way people have
different ways what kind of music are we
talking about all sorts of Music can be
classical can be pop music and you know
just songs when you really know that you
are relaxed
and something I experience actually at
20 000 feet which was the greatest
experience of my life uh in those in
those terms is when you forget that you
have water around you at that point uh
you cannot tell whether you are the
water or water is you there is actually
no separation anymore and I felt that uh
when I was training in a swimming pool I
never could have imagined that I would
feel that way once on top of that
volcano and it happened and it was
absolutely amazing it was you know we
were talking about how life
Consciousness permeates the universe at
that point in time on that volcano that
day
it took me by surprise I was not
expecting it everything around me the
lake was
Arctic blue with all the ray of the Suns
you can
you could tell them apart every single
one of them I was surrounded by Golden
darts
and it was the most incredible
experience and I don't know if it's that
kind of environment that led me to just
you know go into whatever state of
meditation or whatnot but all of a
sudden
there was no separation anymore between
me the water the volcano and if I came
with questions they didn't matter
anymore because for that fraction of a
second it seemed that I had all the
answers of the in the universe was it
the connectedness with everything you
can call it that way I still don't know
what it means you know literally but it
is
a moment where you feel that it doesn't
matter it really doesn't matter anymore
it was a absolutely absolute peace
absolute understanding and it was
incredible it was an absolute awareness
could you describe it as beautiful
that could go beyond that I think that
there is clearly in my mind today no
words that can express how perfect this
was it does that start to speak to why
you love diving or is there something
special about that place
diving at such elevations and volcanoes
you know I started diving pretty much
this is the first thing I did when I was
near water in fact there is a very fun
little incident with my parents me being
on the shore of the lake on vacation I
was
three years old maybe and I had this
little Life Savers you know on my arms
and my parents were not watching and in
my little brain I still can't remember
today saying well
nothing bad can happen to me I cannot
drown if I go underwater see that's the
logic of a three-year-old yes yeah it
kind of works I mean that's yeah well
pretty brilliant so I removed
the Lifesavers that I had and I just
went in the water my mom said before she
could do anything I was under and it was
like a natural thing and for me I felt
immediately at home and and and you know
as little as I was completely and it
goes beyond that and you know this sense
of connectiveness or Oneness or whatever
I always felt
good and and uh underwater so it doesn't
matter really if it's 20 000 feet that
the thing that's better at that point is
that you need to get there so you need
to get with all the gears with your
hiking tracking equipment High
mountaineering gears and when you get on
top of that you have to remove all that
and don't a suit
is there something uh you can speak to
the challenging aspects of that process
or is it just like this rigorous process
that's well designed you have to go
through and you don't think
this is where most of the risk is
because
you can be well prepared but for one
reason or another you get sick you know
and you can get sick not only because of
high altitude sickness it can be a
number of things or you can be tired or
you can catch a cold and then of course
you have the mountain itself